all right I like to pop off each hour
with a little extra helping of Happiness
this is what I'm
[Music]
liking all right there's one guest we've
had on the show more than anyone y'all
to date lifestyle Pro fashion Guru
podcast host and my friend Lawrence
Arion has joined us dozens of times I
don't even know how many times he truly
wants to make people feel beautiful and
wonderful in all the ways that's the
spirit behind his new exclusive fashion
collection which is available starting
to day everybody Welcome Back Laurence
to hi
everybody such a big day going under I'm
going under such a big day it is a big
day you smell good see this collection
you've been planing for a long time it
is 30 years in the making and I will say
this I'm probably having my own American
Idol moment I love it because I feel
like everything I've done has led me to
this place and I have done makeovers for
the last 30 years and for the last 30
years women have told me exact exactly
what is missing when it comes to Fashion
So I listened and this collection
Beautiful by Lawrence zarion exclusively
at QVC is basically a tribute inspired
to all those women it's going to be
cheesy but I've waited a lifetime for
this moment I love it so cheesy
wonderful well we have we have models
here uh with some looks from Beautiful
by Lawrence Darion okay first of all
let's start with Morgan I love a and a
jumpsuit is one and done
and I put her in my crimson red v-neck
flutter sleeve Lux knit jumpsuit and the
best part ladies pay attention Pockets
number
one love pockets and number two it is an
adjustable waistline so women can move
the waistline to celebrate their unique
body their unique shape and their unique
size and your night out when you drink
too much this is one and done you can
dress this up you can dress it down and
this comes in such a celebration of
colors black Navy and crimson red okay r
one I love the red one also machine
washable you're
welcome yes all right what's next all
right next up that is Maddie and the
slack is back I put her in my Mountain
Green wideleg trouser pant and here's
the thing that I love about the trouser
pant because with the waistband I added
adjustable tabs to keep women the
freedom of sizing yeah it comes in an
assortment of colors and then I layer it
on my Lux lace top and what I love about
my lace blouse is I called it the Doris
inspired by my mom because my mom loved
lace and then finally Sophie does have a
choice and I picked my favorite piece
and this is my favorite piece of the
collection and what I've done with my
collection is there are certain people
in my life that have changed my life and
have inspired my life and if I didn't
have amazing women in my life like the
women at QVC I wouldn't be here so this
piece is officially called The Kelly
cardigan come on come here come
here I didn't know you were going there
this is so
cute sleeve long
sleeve rib open front Flyway cardigan
and it comes in four beautiful colors
and every time you want to put something
on that feels something put on the
cardigan that will be your wardrobe best
friend yeah I love that's so sweet love
this is awesome thank you so much
Lawrence I'm liking his poster right
now everyone be sure to check out
beautiful by Lawrence Dar and exclusivly
of QVC specifically my
C usually though at this point in the
show we give our guests $1,000 turn to
by season one partner pilot P make
in the go to R pin of the Kelly Clarks
usually we give a $1000 away but today I
think you're doing all right um so
that's we're going to give it to someone
in the audience how does that sound
anybody want
$1,000 all right well I want you all to
look at that monitor and our cameras are
going to work their magic and one of
your faces is going to pop up right
there let's do
it of
course
what's your name Janice Taylor thank you
well thank you so much for coming I hope
you enjoy
the thank you a big thank you to G
Brooks for hanging out with us all hour
we love him so much y'all have a great
day and if it's not try and change
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home